Hey Youtubers it’s Charlie and during my
Arrow review I asked you all to submit questions
about the epic mess that Slade is making for
Team Arrow the rest of the season.
I picked 10 to answer in this video with one
bonus question.
I tried to stick to the most important things
like new characters, team-ups and related
Flash news.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Q&A videos for big shows just so that
we can talk a little more about the most interesting
parts.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
So let’s answer some questions.
Number 1 - CountSwagula asks Maybe episode
20 "Seeing Red" could be Roy's first appearance
as Red Arrow.
Either Barry Allen coming back or Roy putting
on the tights?
Good question.
There are two things we know, Roy will get
his suit and characters from The Flash are
coming to Arrow or back to Arrow, before the
end of the season.
So like a lot of episode titles I think it
means both things.
There is still a special announcement that
goes hand in hand with episode 20 and it has
a lot to do with episode 19 and the potential
for a supporting character to die.
A lot of the questions tie back into this
so I’ll be elaborating throughout the rest
of the Q&A.
Question 2 - Tom Steven asks I thought it
would be 20 episodes in season 2?
There are currently 23 listed on The Futon
Critic right now.
So what’s happening is there’s a break
next week.
Then on March 19th there’s episode 15 the
Suicide Squad and every week after that will
be a new episode until the finale.
Episode 23 on May 14th.
We only know the titles of the episodes up
to 18 and episode 20.
In order those are, Suicide Squad, Birds of
Prey, Deathstroke and Seeing Red.
We don’t know the names of episodes 19 or
the last 4 yet.
Question 3 - Red Arrow 1596 asks Do you think
Amanda Waller will approach Slade in the season
finale and ask him to join the Suicide Squad,
and what do you think their potential is for
becoming a sort of altogether Big Bad for
Season 3?﻿
So you’re asking if Slade is ever going
to join the Suicide Squad and if they’re
going to be the villains in season 3.
I can say probably not to the first part and
definitely no to the second.
The Suicide Squad are great anti-hero’s.
Those are protagonists that aren’t necessarily
good guys.
Like evil people working with the good guys
toward a common goal.
Under a temporary cease fire.
It’s possible that members of the Suicide
Squad could go rogue in the future, but then
Amanda Waller would just send the rest of
the Squad to kill or capture them.
I’ll talk more about potential Big Bads
for Season 3 when we get closer to the Finale.
There’s still a lot we don’t know about
how this season is going to end.
Question 4 - Sarah Sunshine (no avatar) asks
Do you think that it is possible to see Slades
children sometime later during the shows run,
like Rose or Jericho?﻿
Thank you for asking this question because
I was just thinking about a Darth Vader arc
for Slade.
What I mean is that Darth Vader starts out
as a good person, Anakin Skywalker, and when
you watch the Star Wars movies starting with
episode 1 and ending with Return of The Jedi,
the overarching story becomes The Redemption
of Vader.
So all of Star Wars isn’t Luke’s story,
it’s really the story of Vader’s fall
from grace and ultimate redemption.
What happened to cause Vader to seek redemption.
His children showed up.
In the comics Slade’s children pretty much
hate him for being so evil.
But we don’t really know how Arrow is going
to deal with that relationship.
Slade was lying when he said he didn’t have
any children during the last episode.
Oliver specifically mention Jericho on the
island in episode 12.
It was when Slade first started to freak out
on the Mirakuru.
In the comics he had another son, Grant the
first Ravager who died and a daughter Rose,
who became the second Ravager after her brother’s
death.
They’re kind of like a backdoor to a Teen
Titan’s show with Roy Harper.
I’m crossing my fingers that Arrow goes
the Darth Vader-route with Slade.
With the exception being Slade isn’t going
to die at the end.
Question 5 - Icewhitescarab asks Because there
was a girl with blonde hair and black fingernails
do you think Harley Quinn will be introduced
in the Suicide Squad episode?﻿
I definitely think it’s Harley Quinn, there
are a couple other theories but based on the
Nail polish and the link to the comic books
it makes a lot of sense given the big moments
Arrow has already given us with other A-List
supers like The Flash this season.
There’s even a bigger character coming in
the finale.
Which I will speechify in a little bit.
Question 6 - Michael Hernandez (no avatar)
asks Could the blonde girl in the jail cell
be Terra instead of Harley Quinn?
Tera does have a partnership with Deathstroke
in the comics.
It’s definitely another possibility.
Remember in episode 12 Tremors the earthquake
machine was being bought by someone in Markovia,
that would have been Terra’s father.
In the comics she started working with Deathstroke
and inflitrated the Teen Titans for him.
Hey, I guess if it does turn out crazy hair
is really Terra it would be more evidence
that the CW is trying to develop a Teen Titans
show.
Question 7 - jkfg989 asks Do you think it
is a possibility that Felicity might be Ivo's
daughter?
This is a really good theory, the backstory
Felicity has given us lines up with a lot
of what we know about Ivo on the show.
And it would be one more way to make her part
of Slade completing this full circle revenge
that started with Shado’s death back on
the island.
I definitely think it would add a really nice
dimension to Felicity’s character.
Give her a darker edge and an arc for Season
3.
The big question though is what happened to
Ivo after Slade chopped his hand off?
He didn’t die and the episode kind of cut
off in the middle of that story.
Question 8 - Shihab Shabir asks Do you think
Malcolm Merlin will appear in this "villain
arc"﻿
.
He has to come back at some point.
There are a couple of theories.
He could be working on his own to win over
Thea.
He does care about family, he went nuts when
Tommy died and the only reason he came back
was for Thea.
The other possibility is he’s working with
Slade and using the opportunity to win Thea
over.
Remember, he doesn’t want to hurt her.
I don’t think this is a good theory though.
And we know he’s keeping his distance from
the League of Assassin’s.
But during Heir to the Demon, Sara name dropped
him.
So when Merlyn does come back, and he will,
expect that the League won’t be too far
behind him, either to stop him or to help
him.
His character is linked closely with them
this season.
Question 9 - Elena Podadic asks When Flash
starts will it work with Arrow's storyline
or will it have it's own, so it’s easier
to follow for people who don’t watch Arrow?
Yes, you will be able to watch The Flash without
watching Arrow, but you’d be missing so
many easter eggs and references.
Characters from both shows will jump back
and forth so I’d say to watch Arrow.
It’s so good.
I’m guessing the reason you’re asking
is because you or someone you know is a huge
Grant Gustin fan, but not a fan of the people
on Arrow.
That’s totally okay, but Arrow is a lot
of fun so you should tell your friends they
should totally drink the kool-aide.
Question 10 - Bang Maid asks Do you think
a series of events culminating with Sara dying
and Laurel being injected with Mirakuru and
becoming Black Canary?﻿
So Marc Guggenheim said there’s a special
announcement about episode 19.
He used this Aaron Sorkin quote about an episode
of the West Wing where one of the characters
dies.
We don’t know what the announcement is,
but based on the West Wing reference it sounds
like someone from Team Arrow will die.
Right now the biggest possibilities from least
likely to most likely are:
Laurel Thea and then Sara.
So yes, Sara is highest on my hit-list, it
would fit thematically with Slade completing
his circle of revenge.
Making Oliver choose whether he kills Sara
or Laurel.
The same way Shado died.
Another possibility is that Thea dies and
Merlyn calls down the League of Assassin’s
on Slade.
That’s not as likely because remember Oliver’s
quote.
Ra’s Al Ghul would be trouble for everyone.
Heroes and Villains.
Manu Bennett said that he would be coming
to Starling.
Marc Guggeheim kind of teased a major surprise
like this in the finale.
But it depended on a bunch of stuff working
out behind the scenes.
So it could still fall through.
So yes, he’s coming.
But it’s not official until the Arrow people
make the annoucement.
But they’re doing everything they can to
use the character on the show.
No idea on who would play him or whether it
would be Liam Neeson reprising the role.
Probably not.
and one last Bonus Question - Vijay Krishnan
asks Who do you think was the person who knocked
out Diggle?
That’s actually the Huntress.
If you look closely she’s got belt buckles
here and the stick weapons that look like
the ones in the clips from the Birds of Prey
episode.
So thank you so much for submitting questions
guys this was a lot of fun and thank you for
your patience.
I’ve had a ton of real life work this week
and it makes it really hard to get videos
out on time.
Tonight I’m going to try and catch up on
Community and Hannibal videos.
That might spill over into Saturday.
I also owe you guys South Park Stick of Truth,
new Doctor Who, Game of Thrones and Anime
Club before Monday.
I’ll try and spread it all out.
If you’re just seeing me for the first time,
be sure to subscribe to get all that stuff.
I have a lot of fun making it.
Hopefully someday that will be my only job.
Until then, click here to watch that epic
Arrow Movie Trailer again and click here for
my review of the episode.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!